could tom holland be quitting spider-man
could nowhere home be the last in the
franchise if so does this mean
we have a new bond
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
right so in the last couple of days tom
hollands have done loads of interviews
because no way home is about to hit the
cinemas
and he has been quoted as saying that
maybe
this will be his last outing that maybe
it's time for him to move on and that if
he is still playing spider-man when he
turns 30 then there's been a massive
mistake in his career
he also then mentions miles morales and
maybe that could be even though he
doesn't directly say this maybe that
could be where the spider-man's
franchise goes in the future
well we do know whether mars morales
sent into the spider-verse animated
movie
and that had massive success
that and the mcu might be tempted to go
in that direction
and if they are i think that's probably
a really good idea but how likely is
this unless there is actually a massive
shock at the end of no way home and
peter parker dies or is lost in the
multiverse somehow or something else
then i can't see this being his last
outing it might be the last standalone
movie that tom holland was starring as
spider-man but they're going to have to
do something with the mcu to hand over
that mantle they're going to have to do
something that explains where a new
spider-man is going to come from or is
miles morales character is going to
emerge as the new spider-man
that could be within another movie
potentially um but i'm really hoping
with all the twists and turns we're
already expecting from no way home but
that isn't where this ends up but
it might
tom holland has been quoted as saying
before that when they were making this
movie they treated it from the outset as
the last part of the franchise the
director john watts has called
spider-man movie no way home spider-man
end game in more than one interview now
that is not a subtle hint at where they
think this movie is going that is going
to be the end of a major character the
end of a major franchise
but does this make any sense for tom
holland in his career he has started to
make really big movies um outside of the
spider-man character he's becoming a
genuine a-list star in hollywood
yes of course he's going to move on from
spider-man at some point but it does
feel a bit soon for me i do feel like
there are a couple of more movies that
he could make and definitely a couple
more appearances in other mcu movies
so i'm hoping this isn't the end
but the timing is
suspicious he has more than once talked
about with friends and in interviews
that he would love to play the bond
character now spoiler alert coming up
here the last bond movie with daniel
craig we do see bond die bond gives his
life to protect his child and the woman
he loves
that whole franchise has been massively
successful and we just point out here as
well that it's mgm's biggest and most
profitable franchise so with amazon
coming in and with their
economic might the franchise is going to
be back and it's going to be rebooted
somehow so i've got a theory
how about it's rebooted with a much
younger bond
a lot of the other actors that have been
rumored to become bond like idris elba
are well in their 30s 40s even older i
don't see them doing that because it
wouldn't be a reboot as much it'd just
be sort of like redoing the daniel craig
version of the bond where bond is
getting a little older towards the end
of his career you know his knees are
bust his backs bust there's a new double
07 that takes over his role you know
it's really his retirement and then
obviously
death
what if we see a bond
much younger
what if we see a bond maybe still in the
navy
we can actually get to see how he
becomes a double 07 in the first place
now that would be wicked and an actor
that would be perfect for that is tom
holland
he's british
he's young enough he's definitely
already got a fan base that would really
love him in this role
um
it would be a no-brainer for mgm really
for me to do this
and it would be something a little bit
different without having to mess around
with the character too much
you know maybe he isn't a womanizer at
the beginning maybe you know he is young
and uh naive and stuff but this could be
a franchise actually that we see for the
next 20 years this could be six seven
movies easily and we could see bond
become
the character that we love
i i i love this the bond character for
me from i have a little bit of a
psychology background the bond count of
me is emotionally stunted there was
something broken in his brain we got to
see that with daniel craig really did he
fell in love and that love was taken
away from him and that you know made him
sort of the person he is he is
self-destructive he takes insane risks
and so on and so on it'd be great to see
actually in a little franchise you know
with tom holland from young that he is
maybe not that character but we find out
why he becomes it
so i have actually a source at mgm that
talks to me about stargate and stuff and
give me a few little tidbits about
amazon's plans for stargate
now
i messaged them this morning and just
sort of said is tom holland going to be
the next james bond
they message back a smiley face
now i'm not going to push it because
i've already pushed it a lot with them
to give me more information about
stargate um so i'm not going to push
that but i would say that's a
definite maybe
i don't think anything's decided here
and it is pure speculation in lots of
ways but i do suspect this conversation
is being had with mgm and this is maybe
what's pushing tom holland and
maybe him making big decisions about
this future career
because the timing's right
he's done spider-man he's done three
great movies he's been obviously in
several movies with the mcu universe
wider his
part in end game and so was was
phenomenal and actually really quite
iconic
um
maybe it is time for him to move on
so i am going to put my hat out there
right now i'm going to put my neck on
the block and i'm going to predict
tom holland is going to leave the
spider-man franchise very shortly miles
morales will probably be the new
spider-man character
and our new james bond
will be tom holland
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification do all that business
there come and join us on facebook and
discord links for both are in the
description
as always please guys stay safe and i
will see you next time
[Music]
you